THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ARE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
COME TO ORDER. I'M GONNA MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TO START
THE DAY TO EXPLAIN OUR PROCESSES
THAT WE DEVELOP TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE TUNING IN FOR
THE FIRST TIME. INCLUDING OUR
CONFEREES SO LET ME COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY.
TODAY ALSO AND FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE IS A PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND AN ACCESS
CODE IT IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO SIX FOUR FOUR
ONE TWO FIVE. AND WILL REPEAT
THIS- BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT THAT POINT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO A PULP- WE WILL
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE. AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY BE A YOU
WILL BE ALLOWED TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR
FOLLOWING THOSE RULES AND FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW ONLINE TOOLS SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT SO EVERYONE
CAN BE HEARD. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER I WILL ASK
ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY AND GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE OUR FIVE APPOINTEES THAT
WILL BE UP AT THE SAME TIME. I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO FACILITATE
THAT A LITTLE CLEARER SO THAT
OUR COURT REPORTER CAN KNOW WHO
IS SPEAKING AND ANSWERING
QUESTIONS SO TO MY COLLEAGUES I
WILL PROBABLY ASK YOU TO DIRECT
A QUESTION TO A MEMBER. OF AN
APPOINTEE AND I WILL- I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT APPOINTEE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION SO THAT OUR
COURT REPORTER IS ABLE TO GET
THE NAME OF WHO IS RESPONDING SO
IT MAY TAKE A LITTLE MORE TIME
BUT I PROMISE YOU WE WILL
FACILITATE IT EFFICIENTLY. SO
ARE BEFORE WE BEGIN THE AGENDA
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND SO TO MY COLLEAGUES A
REMINDER TO YOU YOU'LL HAVE TO
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE FOR THE
ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME THAT WE
VOTE SO. BUT THAT MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL. GROW HERE. WELL HERE
KAMLAGER. LAYERED LAYERED HERE.
BATES ATKINS YOUR SECONDS HERE
ONE. WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PRESENT WHICH IS A
QUORUM- SENATOR COM LAGER IS-
CHAIRING A BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
SO SHE WILL JOIN US AS SHE CAN
AND SHE WILL BE BACK AND FORTH.
OUR VICE CHAIR IS. ABSENT TODAY.
SO I JUST TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
IS CLEAR ON ON OUR- WHAT. WE ARE
DOING AND WHO IS PRESENT. I
BEFORE WE TAKE UP B. ITEM NUMBER
ONE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. I WILL ASK
IF WE CAN DO ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. ITEMS FNG
OUR APPOINTMENTS TO THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
ITEMS H. I. N. J. R. TO THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. AND ITEM K. IS TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. IF I DON'T THINK.
THANK YOU. THAT IS A MOVEMENT
FOR ITEM TWO F. THROUGH K. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH BROUGH I KAMLAGER.
LAYERED ARE THERE I BATES ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL SO SENATOR COM
LOGGER CAN I ADD HER VOTE ITEM
NUMBER THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS
TO COMMITTEES I WOULD MOVE THEM
SENATOR THANK YOU BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL ROLL. GROWTH GROW
BY KAMLAGER LAYERED LAYERED I
BATES ATKINS HI ATKINS I ON CALL
AND THAT WILL BE ON CALL IS WILL
WE WILL NOW TURN TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THAT'S ITEM ONE A THROUGH E.
THE APPOINTMENTS OF
COMMISSIONERS TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS AND FOUR OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN FOR THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT THESE ARE ALL FREE
APPOINTMENTS SO THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SERVED US.
ARE ALREADY AND HAVE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN THIS AREA SO I'M
HAPPY. TO INTRODUCE EACH OF
THEM. I WE HAVE ONE A DIANNE
DOGS J. D. ITEM ONE B. DAVID BE
LONG. ITEM ONE SEE SHELVE MINOR
ITEM ONE D. EXCELSA REEF J. D.
ITEM ONE P. TROY TYRA J. D. SO
THAT'S FIVE- COMMISSIONERS FOR
CONSIDERATION. AND WHAT WE WILL
DO IS INTRODUCE EACH OF YOU
INDIVIDUALLY YET LET YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT'S BEEN
HELPFUL AND SUPPORTIVE TO YOU.
AND GO AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS- WE WILL GO
THROUGHEACH- COMMISSIONER AND
BEFORE WE DIDN'T COME TO THE
SENATORS FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. AND SO I WILL START
WITH ITEM I WILL JUST GO ONE A
THROUGH D. N. HI THAT WOULD BE
FIRST AND FOREMOST LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO DIANNE OUR DOGS J. D.
TO- INTRODUCE HERSELF
ACKNOWLEDGED FOLKS. AND THEN I
WILL FOLLOW DOWN THE LIST AND
INTRODUCE THE NEXT COMMISSIONER
SO. I MISS. DOBBS WHY DON'T YOU
GO AHEAD AND WELCOME. FROM HERE
I'M GONNA SENATORS- NAME IS
DIANE DI- I JOIN THE BOARD HE-
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE. AND
THEN LATER ON IN DECEMBER OF
THAT YEAR. GOVERNOR BROWN
APPOINTED ME AS A COMMISSIONER-
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT- GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS REAPPOINTED ME AND
I'M HAPPY TO SERVE. CONTINUE TO
SEARCH. I HAVE OVER TWENTY YEARS
OF PUBLIC SERVICE AND MOST OF
THE TEAM HAS BEEN PUBLIC SAFETY
AND REHABILITATION. THIS IS THE
MOST DIFFICULT JOB THAT I HAVE
DONE BUT IT'S ALSO THE MOST
REWARDING ALL THE JOBS THAT I'VE
DONE. IT TRULY IS MY PLEASURE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE
KNOW FROM PAST THE- APPOINTMENTS
HOW DIFFICULT THIS PARTICULAR
APPOINTMENT AND ASSIGNMENT ARE
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT. LET ME
INTRODUCE AND WELCOME- MISTER
DAVID BE LONG TO MAKE- OPENING
COMMENTS AND INTRODUCTIONS
WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS OF MY NAME IS
DAVID LONG AND I'M HONORED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
CONSIDERED FOR RECONFIRMATION
TODAY. YOU USUALLY WORK FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
STARTING AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER ARE BACK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. I PROMOTED THROUGH
THE RANKS AND ULTIMATELY SERVED
AS THE WARDEN AT ARGUMENT SICK
PRISON CALIFORNIA CITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. FOR TOTAL
OF FIVE YEARS. I'VE NOW SERVED
AS A COMMISSIONER FOR BORDER
PATROL HEARINGS FOR OVER FOUR
YEARS SINCE JANUARY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. I SAW REAPPOINTMENT
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH I FIND THE WORK
DIFFICULT I ALSO FIND IT TO BE
VERY REWARDING. WITH ME TODAY IS
MY- BEAUTIFUL WIFE JANE SHE'S
THE MOTHER OF OUR SIX BOYS. AND
MY STRONG SUPPORTER. I ALSO-
GRATEFUL THAT MY BROTHER JOSEPH
UNANIMOUS SISTER IN LAW KATHY. I
AM VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE TO BE
SENATORS. THANK YOU MISTER LONG
SO NICE THAT YOU'RE YOUR FAMILY
WAS ABLE TO JOIN YOU TODAY AND
SHOW THEIR SUPPORT. LET ME TURN
IT OVER AND WELCOME MISS
MICHELLE MINOR AND SAY WELCOME
AND PLEASE GO AHEAD AND MAKE
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS IN ANY
INTRODUCTION SHE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE. WELCOME. I THINK YOU'RE ON
MUTE MAYBE. OKAY THERE WE GO
WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
SENATORS I AM HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY FOR THE PAST THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS I HAVE PROUDLY SERVED AS A
PUBLIC SERVANT STARTING MY
CAREER AT JUVENILE HALL BEFORE
MOVING MOVING TO THE STATE
SYSTEM OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY NOW THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. AFTER TWENTY
YEARS WORKING WITH YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM I TRANSPORTATION
ADULT CORRECTIONS WHERE I SERVED
AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS I'VE
BEEN A COMMISSIONER ON THE BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND I ECHO MY-COLLEAGUES' SENTIMENT THAT THIS
IS THE MOST DIFFICULT YET
REWARDING. JOB THAT I'VE EVER
HAD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY I WELCOME
ANY COMMENTS OR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU.
LET ME MOVE NOW I TO MISTER
EXCEL SURE REEF J. D. AND SAY
WELCOME TO YOU AND- GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND
ANYONE YOU'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS ONCE AGAIN IT'S A
PRIVILEGE BEING IN FRONT OF YOU
I EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO APPEAR BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO HAVE SERVED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MY
BACKGROUND I'VE BEEN AN ATTORNEY
IN PRIVATE PRACTICE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS AN
HEARING OFFICER FOR VARIOUS
AGENCIES INCLUDING SERVING AS A
JUDGE PRO TEM IN THE LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT. AS WELL AS MY
ASSIGNMENT PRIOR TO MY INITIAL
APPOINTMENT AS A MINISTER OF LAW
JUDGE FOR THEBORDER ROLE HERE
ARE RECOGNIZED AS ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES DO THAT OUR JOB AS
COMMISSIONER IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
HOWEVER IS ALSO SHOWING THE
WARNING PUBLIC SAFETY IS ALWAYS
THE FOUNDATION FOR DECISIONS ARE
I BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE DONE BY
SURE RESPECT TO EVERYONE THAT
INCLUDES. INDIVIDUALS WERE
INCARCERATED AS WELL IN TREATING
THOSE ACROSS IT WITH DIGNITY I
BELIEVE THAT MY WORK IS
COMMISSIONER IS MAKING A
POSITIVE CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
COMMON JUSTICE SYSTEM INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY GIVING
INDIVIDUALS A MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PAROLE IN A
HEARING PROCESS THAT STRIVES TO
BE FAIR. AND RESPECTFUL TO ALL
WHO PARTICIPATES IN OUTLOOK FOR
MANAGING QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAPPEN AGAIN I THINK YOU. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND- WE GO.
TO NOW MISTER TROY- TIRE J. D.
FOR YOUR OPENING COMMENTS%
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS GO RIGHT AHEAD
AND WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IT IS OF AN HONOR TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU I WISHED A
GOOD AFTERNOON TOTHE CHAIR AND
THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND DIED
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS MY REQUIREMENT TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
FOR REAL CLEANING ME AND ALSO.
TO THE DEDICATED STAFF AT THE
BOARD WHO HAS PROVIDED AN
EXCELLENT AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
DURING THESE THESE LAST FEW
YEARS. I AM HERE TO. IN THE
HOPES OF CONTINUING MY PUBLIC
SERVICE OFFERING MY EXPERIENCES
AND TRAINING BOTH AS AN ATTORNEY
AND AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE AND- VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES SO THAT I CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO A PUBLIC SAFETY
RECOGNIZING REHABILITATION AND
CHANGE AND PROVIDING A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL FORUM FOR ALL OF THE-
PARTICIPANTS- WHO APPEAR. BEFORE
US. AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
TURN TO YOU SENATOR LAYERED AND
LET YOU START AND I'M GOING TO
ASK IF YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC
QUESTION- FOR A SPECIFIC
COMMISSIONER. DIRECTED TO THAT
COMMISSIONER FEW WANT ALL
COMMISSIONERS TO RESPOND THEN
LET ME AS THE FACILITATOR GO
DOWN THE LINE AND ASK SO OUR
COURT REPORTER WILL BE SURE AND
GET THE NAME OF THE PERSON WHO'S
GOING TO BE RESPONDING. PERFECT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IN A
MOMENT. THE FIRST ONE WILL BE TO
ALL OF THEM SO FAR- GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP THAT THAT'S COMING. A.
N. R. WOULD JUST SAY THAT I HAD
A CHANCE TO MEET WITH ALL OF YOU
YESTERDAY OR MONDAY. I REALLY
APPRECIATED. AND MY FIRST
QUESTION IS ROOTED IN WHAT OUR
CONVERSATION WAS BECAUSE EACH OF
YOU. HAS A VERY. WORK RELATED
BUT DIFFERENT PATH ON THE WAY
OUT TO THIS BOARD FROM A WARDEN.
ATTORNEY AND STATE SERVICES AND
DIFFERENT THINGS AND SO. OF ONE
OF THE INTERESTING THINGS ABOUT
OUR CONVERSATION WAS ASKING.
WHAT IN YOUR EXPERIENCE DO YOU
DRAW ON TO DO THIS JOB WELL WHAT
. R. R. DID YOU REALLY LEARN
FROM WHAT YOU DID BEFORE THAT
THAT YOU BRING TO THIS AND SORT
OF COLORS WHAT YOU DO AND THEN.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRO TEM DECIDE.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER DOBBS LET ME
START WITH YOU AND THEN I'LL GO
TO THE NEXT PERSON GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOD SENATOR
LAYERED. SO WHAT I DRAW FROM
FROM ALL OF MY VARIOUS POSITIONS
IS- THE FACT THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE ABILITY TO LEARN AND
GROW AND CHANGE AND I SAW
EXAMPLES OF BLACKS WHEN I WORKED
AS A DEPENDENCY ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND I SAW THE AMOUNT
OF TRAUMA THAT THEY EXPERIENCED
AND HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO FIND A
WAY THROUGH THE ACTS. AND NOT
JUST THE CHILDREN BUT ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS AS WELL THAT WHEN GIVEN
THE RIGHT SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
THEY WERE ALSO ABLE TO FIND
WAYS- TO REUNITE THEIR FAMILIES
AND SO THAT IS KIND OF GUIDED
THE IDEA THAT ALL OF THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
HERE BEFORE US HAD MAXIME
ABILITY TO- CHANGE THEIR LIVES.
AND TO LEARN AND TO GROW. THANK
YOU SO MUCH HI MISTER LONG WHY
DON'T YOU GO NEXT. SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE STARTING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE I'VE
SEEN SOME DRAMATIC CHANGES AND-
WAS ALSO PART OF HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE CHANGES
PARTICULARLY AT IN COLLEGE
PROGRAMS AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS. AND I SAW THE EFFECT
IT HAD ON OUR GIVING HOPE TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE.
INCARCERATED AND- YOUR FAST
FORWARD TO TODAY IT'S A MUCH
DIFFERENT MUCH BETTER DEPARTMENT
IN MANY WAYS AND- I BELIEVE THAT
HAVING THAT EXPERIENCES. ARE
REALLY BENEFICIAL FOR ME- IN THE
VALUE WAITING THERE ARE
SUITABILITY FOR PAROLE
UNDERSTANDING THE CULTURE IN
PRISON UNDERSTANDING THE
AVAILABLE OPPORTUNITIES- IT'S
REALLY GIVEN ME A GOOD BASE I
THINK TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH FOLKS THAT
APPEAR BEFORE US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH COMMISSIONER LONG
COMMISSIONER MINOR GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU. I AM I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE WHEN I FIRST STARTED
AS A YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR OF WORKING AS THE
OFFICER IN THE BOARD ROOM SO MY
PERSON OBJECTION TO
COMMISSIONERS WHAT WAS THAT WORK
IN THE BOARD ROOM AND I THOUGHT
THIS WAS NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX I THOUGHT THAT THE
WORK THAT THEY DID WAS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
BACK BENCH- JUVENILE JUSTICE-
CORRECT AND COMMISSIONERS
ACTUALLY SET BOARD ORDERS AND
BASICALLY WORKED THROUGH THE
REHABILITATIVE PROCESS WITH ME
INCARCERATED YOUTH AND SO. WE
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
FROM THAT VANTAGE POINT AND AS I
CONTINUED THROUGH MY CAREER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE I SAW THEM IMPLEMENT
NUMEROUS PROGRAMS RELATED
PROGRAMS- DIFFERENT TYPE OF
COMMUNICATION- PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD. INTERVIEWING I SAW A LOT
OF HAPPEN IN IN DJ OR THE COURSE
OF TIME AND I MOVED TO ADULT
CORRECTIONS SO I BOTH A NOT ONLY
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE WITH AND
JUVENILE I ALSO HAD. EXPERIENCE
WITH THE ADULTS AND SO I WAS
ABLE TO SEE THE PROCESS- KIND OF
MORPHING GROWING CHANGE IN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX WHEN SEC
RPR AND- CDCR I WAS REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES
AND SO TO BE A PART OF. THIS
PROCESS I BELIEVE STILL IT IS
PART OF THE REHABILITATIVE
PROCESS. I THINK MY EXPERIENCE
IN BOTH ORGANIZATIONS. HAS
HELPED ME TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT. AIR OPEN. COMMUNICATION
WITH. THE PEOPLE WHO COME BEFORE
ME. AND IT CERTAINLY BELIEVE
THAT I CAN- IT WILL MAKE THESE
DECISIONS THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT AT TIMES IN A IN A
FAIR. WAY. THANK YOU OUR
COMMISSIONERS THREE. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AS WELL I DO ALSO
BELIEVE IN THE R. C. C. R. AS
FAR AS WE ABILITY SHIN WHEN THIS
QUESTION WAS POLLS ON MONDAY BUT
SOONER OR LATER. DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS AT ANY OPPORTUNITY
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION SOME
CREDIT WAS PART OF THE CAN. WHEN
I LOOK AT MY- TO HEARING AND HOW
HIGH SEEMS THAT YOU RETRAIN I
LOOK AT IT TWO TIER SYSTEM.
FIRST THE PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE I HAVE. REPRESENTING
INDIVIDUALS WERE INCARCERATED IN
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ATTORNEY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY MARC PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE WHAT I FIND
IS THAT. A LOT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO COME BEFORE US
THEY COME FROM THE- EITHER TO
SAINTE MARIE I'M FROM OR SIMILAR
COMMUNITY. AND SO THERE IS A
CONNECT WITH THEM AND ALSO IT
WOULD BE AS WELL. IN SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED NOT ONLY WORDS OF HOPE. BUT
A CONCRETE ROADMAP FOR CHANGE
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY NOT ONLY DO I ENJOY THIS
JOB. I'M SEEKING REPORT. THANKS
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU- GO TO
COMMITTEE FIVE AND GO HEAD.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AS
THERE ARE THREE ASPECTS OF. OF
MY EXPERIENCES THAT RESONATE
WITH ME IN RESPONSE TO THE
SENATORS QUESTION ONE IS. OVER
THE YEARS AND WORKING WITH
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS. THE BILL BOTH IN IN
THE MILITARY WHEN I SERVED IN
THE U. S. NAVY IN THE U. S.
COAST GUARD FOR MANY YEARS THAT
HE LEARNED TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT- VERYDIVERSE
GROUPS. OF ALL LEVELS OF
EDUCATION PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY BUT WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES AND
THAT HAS TAUGHT ME THE VALUE OF
RECOGNIZING THAT. AND WHEN I DID
TO PAROLE HEARINGS ARE IT
REMINDS ME THAT TWO OF THAT NOT
EVERYBODY. GROWS UP THE SAME WAY
OR IS EXPOSED TO THE SAME THINGS
. THE OTHER THING I'VE LEARNED
AS A IN MINISTRY LAW JUDGE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
HEARD BECAUSE- THEY WANT TO BE
HEARD THEY WANT TO BE HEARD AND
LISTEN TO. AND I HAVE FOUND
THAT- MY EXPERIENCE DOING THAT
OVER THE YEARS HAS BENEFITED ME.
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF.
OF PEOPLE WANTING TO BE HEARD
AND BEING TREATED RESPECTFULLY
EVEN IF THEY DISAGREE. WITH THE
ULTIMATE DECISION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU AND THEN
ONE OTHER QUESTION AND I
REVIEWED THE MATERIALS LAST
NIGHT AND I'M SORRY ADDED MASS
THIS DURING THE MEETINGS BUT- I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE INTERESTING
TO HEAR- WE HAVE A CHARGER I DID
IN SOME OF THE MATERIALS
PROVIDED TO ME. OF THE PERIOD OF
DENIAL BEFORE AN INMATE BECOMES
ELIGIBLE FOR THE NEXT PAROLE
HEARING DATE. AND AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THEM
WERE FOR THREE YEARS OR FIVE
YEARS THAT SEEMS TO BE PRO FORMA
. BUT FOR COMMISSIONERS DOBBS
LONG AND MINOR. THERE WERE A
CHUNK OF PEOPLE THAT WERE TEN
YEARS OR FIFTEEN YEARS THAT I
WAS GONNA ASK WHAT ARM. WHAT WAS
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
BEFORE ALLOWING SUCH A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE SOMEONE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR THEIR NEXT PATROL
BOAT PAROLE HEARING AND THAT
WOULD BE DOBBS LONG AND MINOR
THOSE WOULD BE THE THREE OKAY
THANK YOU. LET ME START BY IN A
DIFFERENT ORDER AND GO WITH
COMMISSIONER MINOR FIRST AND
THEN I'LL GO TO LONG AND DOGS
BUT I'LL CALL ON YOU AGAIN
SEPARATELY FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE COURT REPORTER SO-
COMMISSIONER MINOR GO RIGHT
AHEAD. LONG LONG DENIALS ARE
BASED ON. NUMEROUS FACTORS AND
REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
A FENDER CHANGE. AND SO IF THERE
IS AN INMATE WHO HAS SHOWN. AT
PRETTY MUCH ABSOLUTELY NO CHANGE
WHICH WE RARELY SEE. DID WE SET
THAT HAVE DENIAL LINKS BASED ON
CLEAR AND CONVINCING CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT HE THAT
LINK BUT TIME IS APPROPRIATE SO.
IF WE ARE. LIKE YOU LIKE YOU
SAID YOU CAN LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
THERE THERE AND THERE ARE MANY
BUT THERE ARE SOME AND THERE ARE
SIGNS THAT HAVE NOT CHANGED
DON'T WANT TO CHANGE WILL COME
INTO THE HEARING ROOM AND TELL
US. THAT THEY'RE NT CHANGING
AND THAT THEY'RE STILL INVOLVED
IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITY IN THE
INSTITUTION AND THAT THEY HAVE
NOT TAKEN ANY STEPS TOWARDS
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
SO IF WE DON'T FIND BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT EIGHT
LENGTH OF TIME- READY SOONER IS
APPROPRIATE THEN WE ASSIGN. THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BASED ON ALL.
OF THE FACTORS THAT WOULD
REVIEW. THANK YOU ARE. SORRY IS
THAT IS NOW RIVER HAD THAT
PERFECT I COMMISSIONER LONG. SO
I SIGNALED ROW NINETY- IS.
SOMETHING THAT WE DEFINITELY- A
LOT OF THOUGHT INTO AND REALLY
THE MAIN FACTOR IS ARE THEY
STILL DANGEROUS CERTAINLY STILL
VIOLENT TYPICALLY- I DON'T
BELIEVE I'VE EVER SAID A FIFTEEN
YEAR TO UPGRADE BUT I HAVE HAD A
FEW TENURE TO NILES. IN THOSE
CASES- VOTERS TYPICALLY EXTREME
VIOLENCE AND EXTREME RECENT
VIOLENCE AND ARE ALSO- ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY WITH THOSE FOLKS
THAT ARE STILL ENGAGING IN A LOT
OF VIOLENCE IS THIS KIND OF
RESISTANCE TO CHANGE AND
PROGRAMMING. AND SO- DOES THE
FACTORS I THINK IT'S BATES DAYS
SIMPLY DON'T AREN'T READY YET TO
CHANGE AND THEY NEED A LOT OF
PROGRAMMING IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO CONTROL THEIR IMPULSES INTO.
THIS- HE SAYS FROM THE VIOLENT
ATTITUDES AND- BEHAVIORS. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER ODD AND
COMMISSIONER DOBBS. YES SO I'D I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING ALL OF MY-
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID- AND THE
ONLY THING I COULD ADD IS THAT.
FIFTEEN AND TEN YOUR DENIALS ARE
EXTREMELY RARE AND IT'S USUALLY
A CASE THAT THE PERSON APPEARING
BEFORE US IS STILL INVOLVED IN A
HIGH LEVEL OF CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
SO THAT MAYBE TRACKING DRUG INTO
THE PRISON WARDEN ASSAULTS ON
OTHER INMATES- AND OF COURSE ALL
OF THAT PROVIDES A DIRECT LINK
TO THE THEM BEING CURRENTLY
DANGEROUS. AND ADDITIONALLY THE
OTHER ELEMENT IS THAT THEY OFTEN
HAVE NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN
PROGRAMS- AND SO WE CHOSE THE
DENIAL LAND. IF IT'S HIGH DINNER
AND IT'S USUALLY THE ACCENTS OF
PROGRAMMING AND THE CONTINUATION
OF HIGH LEVEL CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE TO THAT
QUESTION AND TO THE OTHER ONE.
OUT OF THEM YOU KNOW BARRING
SOMETHING DRAMATIC THAT TURNS UP
IN THE HEARING I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING ALL FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED. LET ME TURN TO SENATOR
GROWTH AND- LET YOU GO AHEAD GET
STARTED AND LET ME KNOW HOW YOU
WANT TO ASK THE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM THANK ALL OF
YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR- COMING THE POOREST TODAY.
AND I KNOW HOW I- APPRECIATE
WHAT COMMISSIONER DOBBS SAID
THAT THIS IS THE HARDEST JOB
SHE'S EVER DONE BUT THE MOST
REWARDING AND I BELIEVE THAT
COMMISSIONER SHE SAID THE SAME
THING SO- I APPRECIATE YOUR ALL
WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS AND- COMMISSION. FOR THIS
BOARD. I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR
ALL OF YOUIT'S KIND OF LINKS
LEASE SO I DO APOLOGIZE AND THEN
I JUST HAVE TWO QUESTIONS FOR
MISSED OPS. BUT THE QUESTION I
HAVE FOR ALL OF YOU AND ALL OF
THE SENATE PRO TEM DECIDE WHO
GOES FIRST. IS WHAT'S THE MAIN
REASON OR MAIN REASONS THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE NINETEEN FOR.
DENYING PAROLE OR GIVING A
GRANT. AND HOW MUCH SUBJECTIVITY
DO YOU HAVE IN DETERMINING THEIR
SUSTAINABILITY OR AND
SUSTAINABILITY ONCE THEY GET OUT
. OKAY LET ME START IN REVERSE
ORDER AND ASK COMMISSIONER HI
TYRA TO GO FIRST. THANK YOU THE
- REASONS TO GRANT OR DENY
PAROLE WE USE A STRUCTURED
DECISION MAKING FRAMEWORK TO
LOOK AT THESE EMPIRICAL AREAS.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TAUGHT IN OUR
TRAINING THAT REFLECT OF THE OF
MITIGATING RAGER AGGRAVATING
FACTORS IN HOW WE REVIEW OF THE-
INMATES THERE THE- PERSONS OF
PEARL SAID ABILITY- SO THAT
COULD BE. THURMOND. CONDUCT
RELATED IT COULD BE HISTORIC
RELATED STATIC FACTORS WE KNOW
THAT STATIC FACTORS OVER TIME
MAY NO LONGER INDICATE THAT
DANGEROUS SO WE LOOK AT THE MORE
DYNAMIC FACTORS WHICH WOULD BE
CONDUCT AKON DOCUMENTED CONDUCT
IN PRISON ABOUT HOW THEY
INTERACT WITH OTHERS WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED IN THEIR GROUPS
AND PROGRAMS AND ADDRESSING WHAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED AS THE-
CHARACTERS. THAT LED THEM TO
MAKE THOSE. DECISIONS THAT
RESULTED IN THE A COMMITMENT
OFFENSES OR THEIR CRIMINALITY IN
GENERAL. BUT SO- WE LOOK AT
THOSE THINGS. OF YOUR RECENT
MISCONDUCT IS WAITED GIVEN MORE
WEIGHT THAN. MISCONDUCT IN
PRISON FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS YOU
KNOW. THAT HIS RECORD YOU KNOW
MANY MANY YEARS AGO AND SO ALL
OF THAT IS. IT CONTINUING
EVALUATION AND EVERY EVERY CASE
IS DIFFERENT WHICH IS THE
CHALLENGING PART FOR ME EVERY
CASE IS DIFFERENT EVERY ALL OF
THESE FACTORS THAT WE HAVE
EVOLVED AND- BASED ON HOW HOW WE
REVIEW THE RECORD AND THE
RESPONSES AND WHICH INCLUDES THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION OF THE
RISK ASSESSMENT REPORT- AND-
WHETHER OR NOT THE CITY. THE
SUSTAINABILITY. WE ALSO REVIEW
THINGS LIKE PEARL PLANS AND
WHETHER THE PERSON HAS PLANNED
FOR RELEASE WHAT KIND OF SUPPORT
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
. BUT WE ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO FOR. TO DEVELOP. A PROGRAM ON
RELEASE THE DIVISION OF ADULT
PAROLE OPERATIONS WILL ALSO DO
THAT FOR INMATES WHO WHO HAVE
TROUBLE YOU KNOW THEY MAY NOT
HAVE FAMILY SUPPORT THE- AND-
BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE AND THEIR
THEIR CONNECTIONS THEY MAY NOT
HAVE SUPPORT OUT COMMUNITIES SO-
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT- THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS WILL HELP THEM WITH-
IT TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. BUT WE
CAN ALSO ORDER THEM INTO THAT IN
TERMS OF HELPING THEM MAKE THAT
TRANSITION SO THOSE ARE THE
TOOLS THAT WE USE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- COMMISSIONER REEF.
THANK OU IN ADDITION TO
COMMISSIONER CHARLES RESPONSE
WHEN FOCUSING ON THE TOOL THAT
WE USE THE STRUCTURE DECISION
MAKING FRAMEWORK THERE'S
DIFFERENT DOMAINS WE INVESTIGATE
AND ANALYSE THE MOST IMPORTANT
DOMAIN IS THE MORE DYNAMIC
DOMAIN AND THAT'S A MAJOR CHANGE
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEKING THERE IS
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS INCARCERATED
WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK PEOPLE
TO FIRST IDENTIFY THOSE
UNDERLYING RISK FACTORS THAT
CAUSED HIM. TO COME INTO PRISON
SYSTEM NUMBER TWO WE'RE NOT
NEEDING ASIAN PROGRAMMING CHIU
UNDERSTAND OR DRESSED AS AN
ARTIST FACTORS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT ARE THE
INTERNALIZE WHAT THE LEARNED IN
SUCH PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE WILL NOT RETRAIN AND CREATE
ADDITIONAL VICTIMS THE SECOND
PART A QUESTION ASKED MR TARVER
SPOKE ONE IS THE- ROLE PROCESS
AS FAR AS YOUR POOL PLANS WE'RE
NOT BE HAPPY. TO PLAN TO ADDRESS
THOSE UNDERLYING RISK FACTORS
SUCH AS GANG INVOLVEMENT CLASS
OPENS OF USE INVESTING VIOLENCE
IN SUCH WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ANY MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
IN PLACE ARE THERE WRITTEN FOR
ABLE TO ARTICULATE DURING MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN AND WHAT WE MEAN. BY
THAT IS. IN IS GREAT PAROLE
THEIR NEXT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE OWNERS WHY TO ONE SIGN UP TO
TALK. OF THINGS OF OR- AND WE
NEED TO READ ONE SIGNS WARNING
TERM CHU WHAT RESOURCE GONNA
TURN TO THE NEXT THEY ABLE TO.
ADDRESS THOSE AS- WE ALSO FOCUS
ON IT BEING PRO AT OF THE CITY'S
ARTS FAR AS WHAT. IMAGES TO MAKE
SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
REALLY TO. AND NOT RELEASED BACK
INTO ME RECENTLY WITH GET MY
SOURCE ALIBAG BY ACTUAL KIND
SCHEME. THAT CAN BE PUT TO USE
IN THE POINT SYSTEM AND ONE SURE
THAT. ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH INMATES OR ITS
INDIVIDUAL. WHO HAVE BEEN.
INVOLVE IN DIFFERENT CRIMES. IN
SO. HAVING MORE SCHEME HAVE MEAN
A STRONG ETHIC WHILE IN PRISON
IT'S A GOOD INDICATOR THAT THEY
WANT TO USE THOSE SKILLS IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL. AND LASTLY WE
ALSO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE. SPECIAL CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
GRATEFUL. NOT ONLY FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT ALSO FOR THE SUCCESS
OF ANY INDIVIDUAL. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE'S NO HEALTH CONCERNS WE
CAN REFER THEM TO WHAT USED TO
BE CALLED CONTROL THE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC WHICH IS NOW THE
BEHAVIORAL. ARE REINTEGRATION
PROGRAM WE SEEM FOR THEM
THEY'RE- ALSO REFERRED HIM TO A-
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM OR
SUBSIDIES PROGRAM WIDELY REDUCE
MANUFACTURERS AT A STATE ON. A
TRACKING DO NOT RE OFFEND AS
WELL. THANK THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER COMMISSIONER
MIND. OKAY IN ADDITION TO THE
START TO SEE MAKING THAT WE HAVE
THAT WE UTILIZE WE ARE THERE'S
ALSO CASE THERE KIND OF THERE'S
A CODE THERE ARE DIFFERENT HERE
IT FOR WE LOOK AT TO AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE AND MY FOR
COLLEAGUES RESEARCH. SO WHEN IN
LOOKING THE NILE GRANTING A POOR
WE CONSIDER MANY FACTORS AND
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
FACTORS AND THE DESTRUCTION
DECISION MAKING FRAMEWORK AS
HELP SAYS REALLY PUT ALL OF
THOSE PIECES TOGETHER AND-
REALLY AT THE VALUE WAIT THE
RISK FACTORS AND LOOK AT CURRENT
DANGER IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
AND THEN MAKE AB INCARCERATED
PERSONS ABILITY TO. BE PROSOCIAL
IN THE COMMUNITY OR NOT- AND I
THINK. I THINK THEY COVERED YOU
KNOW WHAT. HELLO CONDITIONS AS
WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY THAT WE-
THE ABILITY TO SET. QUITE A FEW
DIFFERENT PEOPLE CAN. TUNING
SHORE SUCCESS. FOR- PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU ARE
COMMISSIONER LONG. THANK YOU-
I'M SORRY I MIGHT NEED IT NO
YOU'RE GOOD WE HEAR YOU OKAY
GREAT I GOT A NOTICE THAT I WAS
ON MUTE. BOB DYLAN SO I AGREE.
COMPLETELY WITH THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES. ARE THE STRUCTURE
DECISION MAKING FOR MADISON L.
SEVEN SPACE. FRAMEWORK THAT
THERE ARE REALLY CAN INFORM OUR
DECISION MAKING- AND CERTAINLY.
UNDER THE LAW WE SHOULD NORMALLY
GRATEFUL OF MY SERVICES AT OUR
CURRENT NEXUS EVIDENCE OF THE
CURRENT ASSISTANT. DANGEROUS TO
US AND- YOU KNOW THE EVIDENCE
TYPICALLY DOES COME IN THE FORM
OF BOB NO MISCONDUCT AND FOR-
CRIMINAL THINKING IT WILL COME
OUT OFTENTIMES IN A HEARING- AND
SO. OUR THE FRAMEWORK REALLY IS
THE ESSENTIAL FACTORS- I DON'T
HAVE A LOT TO ADD TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY LAID OUT
PRETTY THOROUGHLY BUT- THE
FRAMEWORK REALLY HELPS US. IN IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER OF
COMMISSIONER DOBBS. THANK YOU I
AGREE WITH ALLOF THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES THE ONLY THING
I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IS
YOU KNOW PART OF- GOING THROUGH
THE STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING
FRAMEWORK HAS US LOOKING APPS.
OF THE PERSON BEFORE US PRIOR
HISTORY AND SO OFTEN TIMES WE
SEE THE PERSON BEFORE US HAVE
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF PRIOR
FAILURES ON ROLE. AND JUST SO
WHEN THAT IS THE CASE. IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO REALLY LOOK
AT WHAT'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
THIS TIME HOW. ARE THEY NOW FOR
SUCCESS AND AGAIN THAT WILL
INVOLVE. VERY SOME VERY DETAILED
WORLD FINDS THAT REALLY COVERS
ALL THE BASES. IN AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS WITH THEM IN
THE PAST AND REALLY SET UP IN
SUCH A WAY TO HELP THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THIS TIME AROUND.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER THANK
YOU. I DO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION FOR COMMISSIONER AND
MINOR. AS I LIKED WHAT YOU SAID
AND COMMISSIONER JOB SAID THE
SAME THING BASICALLY. M. THE
COMMISSION MINOR CAN YOU GIVE ME
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE SET
CONDITIONS OF PAROLE LIKE IS IT
. THE JOB THE- WHAT'S WHAT'S
YOUR SET CONDITIONS OF PAROLE.
WE CAN SET CONDITIONS- FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR SIX
MONTHS WHICH GIVES THEM THAT'S
ONE LESS THING THEY HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE ACTUALLY HAVE
HOUSING THAT THEY ARE IN THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. YOU
KNOW TRYING TO FIND SOMEWHERE TO
GO WE CAN SET CONDITIONS THAT
THEY HAD- PROBLEMS WITH
SUBSTANCES WE CAN SECOND EDITION
IS THAT THEY ARE. READ IT- THAT
THEY HAVE- ARE PARTICIPATE IN A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAM OR- WE CAN SET
CONDITIONS THAT THEY- ARE IF
THERE ARE SEX OFFENDERS THAT
THEY PARTICIPATE IN SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT PROGRAMMING IF
THEY'RE- YOU KNOW BEEN.
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THAT THEY PARTICIPATE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAMS SO WE
CAN SET A LIST AND IT IT IS ALL
CONNECTED TO THE CRIME FOR WHICH
THEY ARE PRESENT SO IF THEY YOU
KNOW HAD ISSUES. IN THE PAST I'M
HOMELESSNESS- YOU KNOW. WE CAN
EXPECT THOSE CONDITIONS SO THAT
THEY ARE MORE SUCCESSFUL AT THE
PAST PROBLEMS WITH GANGS WE CAN
SET GAME CONDITIONS THAT THEY
ARE NOT TO- PARTICIPATING GANG
ACTIVITY- WHERE THAT. THAT THAT
THE CLOTHING OF GANG MEMBERS
WHICH TOO MANY OF THEM ARE FROM
WAY PAST THAT BUT WE CAN STEP
THOSE CONDITIONS SO WE SET THE
CONDITIONS BASED ON REALLY-
THEY'RE WANTING. THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE CAN SET CONDITIONS
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY CONTACT
WITH THE VICTIMS OF THE VICTIMS
NEXT OF KIN THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT SOMETIMES WE CAN ALSO
SET CONDITIONS THAT MAY NOT LIVE
IN A CERTAIN. AREA IS SO THAT
THE VICTIMS ARE NOT- WORRIED
THAT THEY'RE IN IN THAT THE SAME
COUNTY THAT THERE AND- WE HAVE
A- PRETTY GOOD- WE HAVE A PRETTY
. LIST THAT WE FOLLOW IF WE HAVE
PROBLEMS OR QUESTIONS HAVE A
GREAT LEGAL TEAM THAT WE- CAN.
CALL AND ASK FOR STATE CAN DO
THIS CAN WE DO THAT WHAT YOU
KNOW AND REALLY ASSISTANCE WITH
THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT-
INCARCERATED PERSONS SUCCESSFUL
IN EVERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU AM. I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
COMMISSIONER JOBS- DOES THE DID-
BPH HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
CONSIDER LATE REQUEST TO ALLOW
CRIME VICTIMS OR THEIR NEXT OF
KIN TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
HEARINGS. GO AHEAD COMMISSIONER
DOBBS. HELLO AT THIS TIME THE
BOARD HAS ASKED OF HIM FOR YOUR
RANGE IN PLACE- THAT REALLY
ALLOWS FOR VICTIMS TO GIVE THE
BOARD I NOTICED THAT THEY PLAN
TO ATTEND- SO THAT IS THE
CURRENT PROCESS IN PLACE PRIOR
TO THAT. THREATENS COULD-
NOTIFIED THE BOARD OF THEIR
INTENTION FOR THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS AND THEN THAT WAY THE
BOARD KNOWS- TO PROVIDE NOTICE
TO BOTH VICTIMS AND TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
WILL NEED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND PROCESS WHICH IS A-
VERY STRESSFUL PROCESS. FOR
VICTIMS. THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
DOT I HAVE FURTHER THANK YOU
MATT PER. THANK YOU- I HAVE
BASICALLY JUST ONE I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES- I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THAT THEY ASK I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
STATEMENTS FOR WHICH YOU. ARE
MADE COMMENTS ABOUT YOUR
PERSONAL- ROLE AS AS A
COMMISSIONER. I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT. HOW IT'S GOING USING THE
REMOTE ACCESS ON CONDUCTING
HEARINGS DO YOU SEE ANY BENEFITS
OR DRAWBACKS ON THE TECHNOLOGY.
AND I CERTAINLY. INSURANCE I
THINK TO TAKE OFF THE FROM THE
QUESTION- CENTER GROVE ASK THE
BOARD ENSURING THE VICTIMS AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. AND CERTAINLY IN
MAKES BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEIR ATTORNEYS TO RECEIVE
A FAIR HEARING JUST JUST CLOSELY
HOW IS IT WORKING IN THIS
PANDEMIC AND YOU'RE CONDUCTING
THE HEARINGS. AND I YOU KNOW I
DON'T NEED TO GO DOWN THE LINE
AND ASK EVERYONE BUT FOR THE
COURT REPORTER SAKE I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE IF YOU JUST WANT TO
KIND OF RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT GIVE ME
YOUR FEEDBACK I DON'T NEED
EVERYBODY TO ANSWER. I SEE THAT
COMMISSIONER LONG HAS HAS RAISED
HIS HAND AND THEN I'LL GO TO YOU
COMMISSIONER TERRA BUT WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH COMMISSIONER
LOG THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR. I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING
INITIALLY- AND- WE HAVE AMAZING
SUPPORT FROM THE BOARD OF REALLY
HELPED US NAVIGATE THROUGH THE
FIRST FEW MONTHS OF A VIDEO
CONFERENCE HEARINGS ARE. I
BELIEVE THE THEY'RE VERY
EFFECTIVE SILENCE CONCERNED
INITIALLY THAT'S NOT HAVING TO
FACE TO FACE CONTACT PERSON.
WHO'S GOING TO. CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC OF THE HEARING AND I
FOUND IN MY EXPERIENCE IT REALLY
ASKED. AND THE OTHER THING
THAT'S REALLY GREAT IS THAT IT
DOES ALLOW YOU TO FIX IT FOR
INCREASED PARTICIPATION BY
VICTIMS AND VICTIMS FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND BUT HAD. BECOMES
FAMILY MEMBERS PARTICIPATE FROM
AS FAR AWAY AS IT IS EUROPE AND-
LATIN AMERICA THAT PROBABLY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING OF
THE WINDS. AND SO THERE'S AN
ADVANTAGE THERE AS WELL. AND I
REALLY YOU KNOW WHEN YOU AT THE
L. ARE REALLY NO- STATISTICALLY
SIGNIFICANT. IN THE OUTCOMES SO
I THINK OVERALL IT'S A BENEFIT
WE ALSO. ARE NOT. DRIVING THE
CARS UP AND DOWN THESTATE
BURNING GAS AND- IT MEETING
CARBON EMISSIONS AND SO THERE SO
THERE'S A LOT OF POSITIVES THAT
I SEE. ARE YOU JUST MADE-
SENATOR LAYER TO SMILE WHEN YOU
REFERENCE THE FORMER SECRETARY
NATURAL RESOURCES- SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT- AND- CERTAINLY I THINK
WE HAVE FOUND DOING REMOTE
PARTICIPATION HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BIT MORE CUMBERSOME AT TIMES BUT
I THINK WE HAVE NOTICED THAT
PEOPLE WHO WOULDN'T ORDINARILY
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE HAVE DONE
SO. THAT IS GOOD TO HEAR-
COMMISSIONER TYRA YOU WANTED TO
COMMENT. I DID I IF I GREW WITH
COMMISSIONER ALONG- IT'S BEEN
OVERALL A BENEFIT FOR ALL AND IT
DID START WITH SOME TREPIDATION
AND A FEW HICCUPS- BUT OVERALL I
THINK THE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH THE
DRAWBACKS. OF BECAUSE WE DO SEE
INCREASE PARTICIPATION- WITH THE
VICTIMS AND THE VICTIMS FAMILY
MEMBERS- WHEREAS BEFORE THEY
WOULD HAVE TO COME TO THE
PRESENT IN PERSON. WHICH IS A
VERY CUMBERSOME PROCESS. OR IF
THEY WANTED TO PARTICIPATE BY
THE VIDEO THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO THE DISCOURAGE OFFICE BECAUSE
OF THE COMPATIBILITY WITH THE
EQUIPMENT- AND NOW. WE'VE
TRANSITION AND THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE FROM FROM HOME AND-
I FIND THAT THAT IS A MUCH MORE.
REASONABLE AND MORE COMFORTABLE
SITTING IN A VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
AFTER SEATING. FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS. I WONDER IF YOU
ANTICIPATE TO- CONTINUE UNTIL
ALLOW THAT AS A POSSIBILITY JUST
BECAUSE ONCE PEOPLE YOUR FIRST
ONCE YOU'RE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY A
DIFFERENT WAY TO BECOMES MORE
CONVENIENT FOR YOU YOU DON'T
WANT TO GIVE THAT UP BUT- THAT'S
A QUESTION FOR I GUESS ANOTHER
DAY. I DIDN'T WANT TO CUT
ANYBODY OFF IF ANYONE ELSE WANTS
TO COMMENT WHY. DON'T I KEEP YOU
BUT I ALSO NOTICED THAT- SENATOR
COM LONGER IS HEARING AND MY
FEAR IS ALWAYS THAT SHE WILL BE
SNATCHED AWAY AGAIN TO. FINISH
HER JOB IS BUDGET SUB SO
COMMISSIONER ARMY COMMISSIONER
US SENATOR- IF YOU ARE PREPARED
AND READY WHY DON'T I TURN THE
MICROPHONE OVER TO YOU TO ASK
COMMENTS AND WHAT I AM DOING TO
HELP- THE COURT REPORTER. IS IF
YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR EVERYONE
THAT I WILL FACILITATE EACH NAME
SO THAT THE COURT REPORTER CAN
GET THE NAME DAY OUT SO IF YOU
JUST WANT TO DIRECT IT TO A
COMMISSIONER YOU CAN IF YOU WANT
EVERYONE TO ANSWER A QUESTION
THAT I WILL FACILITATE THAT EACH
ONE ANSWERING GOING. PERFECT
THANK YOU MADAM FOR ATTEMPTS SO
I HAD THEM. A QUESTION FOR. MISS
MINOR- AND THIS IS- SPECIFIC TO-
IN CARS RATED WOMEN- ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT- HAD- MAYBE SEXUAL
ABUSE OR- TRAUMA IN THEIR PAST
THAT MIGHT HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT LED
THEM TO BECOME INCARCERATED.
JUST WANTING TO KNOW HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE- HOW THEIR PAST TRAUMA
PLAYS INTO THEIR CRIME WHEN
THEY'RE COMING BEFORE YOU.
THAT'S THE COMMISSIONER MINOR GO
AHEAD. SO PRIOR TO TOWN AT THE
INCARCERATED PERSON EVEN COMING
INTO THE HEARING I WILL HAVE
REVIEWED ALL OF THE INFORMATION
THAT I FOUND THAT THAT IS IN THE
RECORD REGARDING THEIR PAST
TRAUMA- BUT WE WOULD HAVE. SOME
CONVERSATION CERTAINLY WE DON'T
WANT TO TRIGGER ANY- ANYTHING
WITHIN A ACT WITH THE PERSON
WHO'S HAD THAT HAPPEN FROM A BUT
WE DO TALK ABOUT THE TRAUMA
THERE'S ALSO A RISK ASSESSMENT
THAT GIVES REALLY GOOD IDEA
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED. IN THE-
INCARCERATED PERSONS LIFE AND SO
WE TALK ABOUT- I ASK AND TELL ME
WHAT THE FACTORS WERE THAT
BECAUSE YOU DO X. Y. Z. AND MANY
TIMES IT DOES CONNECT BACK TO
TRAUMA AND THEN WE WORK- WE TALK
ABOUT REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS
THAT. A PERSON HAS TAKEN TO-
HAVE MANAGED AND WORK THROUGH
THE TRAUMA SO I DO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION A PERSON'S- TRAUMA
AND ALL THAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH AND IN THE LIGHT IT'S
SPECIFICALLY- EVEN WHEN WE HAVE
A VERY YOUNG PEOPLE. THAT ALSO
HAS A BEARING ON WHAT I LOOK AT
IN TERMS OF DETERMINING HOW THAT
TRAUMA HAS PLAYED INTO THE CRIME
THAT. THEY COMMITTED. THANK YOU
FOR I WAS WONDERING I'M SURE IF
I COULD ALSO ASK THE SAME. TO MR
SHARIF- YES GO AHEAD-
COMMISSIONERS TO REVIEW HER ID
MAKE SURE YOU HEARD THE QUESTION
. IDEATE THANK YOU CENTER FOR
THAT QUESTION I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES INITIAL MINOR. IN
ADDITION TO RECOGNIZING
UNDERLYING TRAUMA ONE COURTNEY
WHAT WE ALSO WANT TO SEE IS
WHETHER OR NOT. THE INDIVIDUAL
HAS BEEN PEOPLE TO CREATE COPING
MECHANISMS TO DEAL WITH THE
TRAUMA. OFTENTIMES YOU BECOME A
CANNOT BE WAS ALL RIGHT. SO
SIGNIFICANT CONTINUATION
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES. WHAT YOU
WANT WHEN YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
IS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE THESE COPING
MECHANISMS TOOLS THEY CAN
UTILIZE. SO THAT THE ONE
CREATING THE VICTIMS THEMSELVES
BECAUSE OF ALL HER WOULD BE THE
SAME THAT HURT PEOPLE HURT
PEOPLE. CONSOLE THE MAIN CONCERN
IS PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT ALSO WOULD
BE CARP. CONCRETE A RISK
ASSESSMENT S. COMMISSION MINOR
INITIATED IS A DEEP. SO SPEECH
INTO THAT AREA AND SO WHAT WE DO
NOT WANT TO DO IS OPEN THOSE
WARMS UP. HERE BUT WE DO WANT
RECOGNIZE THAT TRAUMA AND
WHETHER OR NOT THE INDIVIDUAL.
THOSE COPING SKILLS REPORT THANK
YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU AND MY
QUESTION IS MY LAW I WONDERING I
WAS TOLD THAT THE RESIDENT. RATE
ARE LOWER FOR THOSE THAT COME OF
YOU- FOR YOUR PAROLE HEARINGS
RATHER THAN THOSE WHO ARE JUST
RELEASED. CAN YOU SORT OF SHARE
ON THAT. MISTER LONG GO AHEAD.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR- I BELIEVE THE-
THE RECIDIVISM RATES. BASED ON
THE DATA FROM CDC ARE ARRANGED
FROM ABOUT THREE TO FIVE
PERCENT- THAT'S A THREE YEAR
RECIDIVISM RATES FOR NEW
MISDEMEANORS OR FELONIES VIOLENT
FELONIES IS LESS THAN 1% AND SO-
YOU. IS THAT IS THAT YOUR
QUESTION DOES IT DOES THOSE ARE
ALL SINGLE DIGIT NUMBER I LOVE
THEM- AND THEN MY FINAL QUESTION
I GUESS WILL BE FOR- MISS DOBBS
AND MISTER TYRONE THAT WAY
EVERYONE WILL HAVE HAD A CHANCE
TO SAY SOMETHING- I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU ALL ARE IN
TOUGH POSITIONS BECAUSE YOU'RE-
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE PAROLE
HEARINGS TO SEE PEOPLE'S TO
GAUGE THEIR- SUCCESS IN
REHABILITATION SO THAT THEY CAN
BE RELEASED- NONE OF YOU I DON'T
BELIEVE HAVE CRYSTAL BALLS OR
AREN'T MAGICIANS- OR CAN PREDICT
THE FUTURE BECAUSE IF YOU COULD
YOU PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE IN
THESE JOBS- AND- YET. I CAN
IMAGINE THAT THE LAST THING
ANYONE WANTS. IS TO. PICK UP THE
PAPER AND SEE A NEWS ARTICLE
ABOUT SOMEONE. INVOLVED IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT CAME
BEFORE YOU- WHICH COULD CREATE A
LOT OF TREPIDATION. WHEN IT
COMES TO APPROVING OF FOLKS- AND
GRANTING THEM A REQUEST FOR
PAROLE SO HOW DO YOU SORT OF
RECONCILE ALL OF THAT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE GOAL IS YOU KNOW TO TALK TO
FOLKS AND TO ASSESS THEIR
SUCCESS IN THEIR REHABILITATION.
IT IS NOT TO SUBJECTIVELY GAUGE
THEIR DEGREE OF REMORSE AND IF
IT JOBS WITH YOU AND IT IS
ULTIMATELY TO RELEASE THEM SO
THAT THEY CAN ENTER BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES HOPEFULLY WITH THE
PLAN THAT HAS BEEN PUT TOGETHER
WITH OTHER FOLKS THAT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL. SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU SORT OF
RECONCILE THE STRESS OF THE
ANXIETY OF WHAT THE PUBLIC.
UNDERSTANDS WITH REGARDS TO YOUR
PROCESS AND HOW PEOPLE SEE FOLKS
WITH CRIMINAL- PATH AND THE GOAL
TO HELP FOLKS GET PAROLED SO
THAT THEY CAN GET BACK INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES LET'S START A
COMMISSIONER I THINK JOBS- CAN
GO FIRST AND THEN AND THEN I'LL
GO TO COMMISSIONER ODD TYRA SO
COMMISSIONER JOBS GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER. WE'RE
WE'RE ALL GETTING OUR TITLES
WRONG I STARTED THAT THAT MESS
GO AHEAD MMHM. IT'S IS- IT'S
SOMETHING ALWAYS A YOU KNOW
FOREFRONT OF OUR MINDS ARE WE
MAKING THE RIGHT DECISION YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE CHANCES THAT
THIS PERSON WILL BE THE ONE WHO
WILL RE OFFEND AND COLLEAGUES.
INCREDIBLE HARM TO SOMEONE ELSE.
AND I THINK BAO THAT. WITH THE
AMOUNT OF TRAINING THAT WE HAVE
. AND THE WORK THAT GOES INTO
REALLY AFFECTING THAT PERSON'S
RISK FACTOR THEIR PREPAREDNESS
FOR SUCCESS. AND I LET THAT
DRIVE MY DECISION ARE THEY TRULY
READY HAVE THEY DONE THE WORK-
WHAT DOES THEIR BEHAVIOR CHAU
HAVE THEY BEEN SHOWING
REHABILITATION FOR SOME TIME.
AND I LET THAT GUIDE MY
DECISION. YOU KNOW THERE IS NO
REASON TO BASE MY DECISION ON
THE VERY SMALL PROBABILITY THAT
THIS PERSON MIGHT RECEIVE THE
BATES WHEN THE BULK OF THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS OTHERWISE. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER ODD
COMMISSIONER TYRA. THANK YOU
SENATOR I CONCURWAS- USER DOBBS
IT IS OUR TRAINING- IT IS THE
FRAMEWORK THAT- WE USE- THE
STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING MODEL
WITH THE RISK FACTORS AND THE
DYNAMICS THAT GO INTO HOW WE
CONDUCT THE HEARINGS WHAT WE SEE
IN THE RECORD THE- THE
COMPREHENSIVE RISK ASSESSMENT
AND- THE- HER GOAL. OF MAKING
TERKEL'S THAT WE- HAVE
IMPLEMENTED TO GAUGE THE LEVEL
OF THE SUITABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE READY TO BE
RELEASED- AND B. WE'RE HAVING
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT FOR ALL
PLANTS ANOTHER KEY ASPECT. TO
GAUGE THAT LEVEL OF SUCCESS AND
TO ENSURE THAT SUCCESS. AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY- I ALSO
CONSIDER THE NUMBERS THAT WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE 325%
OF THE FELONIES AND MISDEMEANORS
WITHIN THE THREE YEAR PERIOD OF
BEING RELEASED THE LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT. OF THE VIOLENT FELONIES
AND THAT ALSO. CONFIRMS THAT THE
WAY WE DO THINGS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR- I
THINK I. GIVEN WHAT EVERYONE HAS
GONE THROUGH I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION AND I'VE BEEN ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR A LITTLE
WHILE NOW AND SO I THINK I HAVE
SEEN ONE OR TWO OF YOU BEFORE-
AT ONE POINT BEFORE- I WAS THE
PRO TEM OF THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE. I BROUGHT UP AN ISSUE
RELATED TO TRANSGENDER- THE
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING INMATES. AND
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND AT THAT
POINT I THINK. THE BOARD ARE
LIMITED FURTHER TRAINING AND I
JUST AM INTERESTED I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE HAD. MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMUNITY COME FORWARD BUT A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND I JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW
UP SINCE I HAVE THIS RARE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SIT THROUGH
ANOTHER CONFIRMATION HEARING AND
ASK- AND I'M GONNA DO LIKE I DID
LAST TIME AND SEE IF ANYONE
WANTS TO ANSWER AND THEN ALL ALL
LIKE KNOWLEDGE YOU. IF YOU HAVE
IF THAT TRAINING NUMBER ONE YOU
WERE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN WAS
IT HELPFUL AND TO HAVE YOU HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. ADDRESS ANY
MEMBER OF THE TRANSGENDER OR
GENDER NONCONFORMING. COMMUNITY
AND ONE OF YOUR HEARINGS AND
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RELATE TO. US AND I'LL IF ANYONE
WANTS TO ANSWER I WOULD LOVE
THAT ALL OF KNOWLEDGE YOU- YOU
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE HAD ANY
CASES BUT- OKAY ARE. A GREAT
COMMISSIONER DOGS I'LL GO TO YOU
FIRST AND THEN- COMMISSIONER
TYRA. THANK YOU- SO YES IHAVE
HAD SEVERAL TRANSGENDER INMATES
APPEAR BEFORE ME. AND- EMAIL
LIKE ANY OTHER OF THE INMATES
WHO ARE PREPARED FOR PAROLE THEY
HAVE DONE THE WORK NECESSARY TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
SUCCESSFUL LOOKS LIKE FOR THEM
ON THE OUTSIDE AND CERTAINLY FOR
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE. THEY HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO FACE OUT THERE.
AND I HAVE BEEN. PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED BY HOW WELL PREPARED
THEY ARE TO FACE THOSE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THEIR GENDER STATUS-
I BELIEVE THAT. THE CITY C. R.
HAS DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
PROVIDING THEM WITH SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED ARMED THERE CAN ALWAYS
BE IMPROVEMENTS I THINK THE
AWARENESS IS THERE NOW TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY DO HAVE SOME
UNIQUE CHALLENGES BEING IN CDC
ARE ARMED AND SUPPORTS ARE IN
PLACE TO HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL
. COMMISSIONER THANK YOU FOR
THAT- THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE
COMMISSIONER TYRA. THANK YOU
SENATOR RIGHT I'VE HAD A FEW
TRANSGENDER INMATES I WOULD SAY
IT'S VERY INFREQUENT I CAN
COUNT- RECOLLECT MAYBE MAYBE TO
A DURING MY- PRIOR TERM- BUT IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT. WE TALK
ABOUT IT THE HEARINGS- HOW THAT
WOULD IMPACT THE PREPARATION FOR
PAROLE AND THINGS TO CONSIDER
UPON RELEASE AND I ECHO
COMMISSIONER DOBBS THE IN. THE
THE PEOPLE THAT I SEE HAVE A
DONE A- MUCH MORE PLANNING AND
THERE THERE'S MUCH MORE
AWARENESS. OF WE TALK ABOUT HOW
THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDRESSED-
WE AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
NOT ONLY IDENTIFIED IN THE
RECORDS WHICH IS A RELATIVELY
NEW THING NOW. IT IS. DOCUMENTED
IT SOMEWHERE IN THE PRISON
RECORDS SO WE KNOW IN ADVANCE
AND A IF WE DON'T WE TALK ABOUT
IT SO THE AWARENESS IS THERE.
AND IT IS- I'VE BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO BY HEARING
HEARINGS THAT I DO. QUESTIONER
THANK YOU AND I COMMISSIONER
DOBBS THANK YOU FOR REFERENCING
CDC ARE BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF
THE MAJOR CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
HAD WITH THEM. ABOUT YOU KNOW
FEEDBACK WE'VE GOTTEN FROM. FROM
INMATES SO I'M I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT DOTS ARE BEING CONNECTED IN
THAT REGARD AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THE
RESPONSES I DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF
MY COLLEAGUES COVER A LOT OF
GROUND. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. I'M
GOING TO DO A QUICK REMINDER
ABOUT OUR- PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER- SO THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
PREPARED FOR THAT AS WE HEAR
FROM MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT MIGHT BE HERE PHYSICALLY.
SO THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBERS ON THE SCREEN AGAIN
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THE ACCESS
CODE FOR THAT IS TWO SIX FOUR
FOUR ONE TWO FIVE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE INTO
ANY WITNESSES I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE. ARE YOUR WHERE- ONE PERSON
AT A TIME BUT IT IT LOOKS TO ME
LIKE WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THAT PROBLEM. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO-
THE TELECONFERENCE. AND WELCOME
OUR MODERATOR BEFORE THE
MODERATOR- CALLS ON YOU I WANT
TO. SAY THIS TO ANY WITNESSES
WHEN YOU SPEAK I NEED YOU TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT. AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER
PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY
AND WITH THAT LET ME WELCOME OUR
A. T. AND T. MODERATOR. TO THE
HEARING. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THE COMMAND IS. ONE
ZERO. IT LOOKS LIKE I DO HAVE
ONE COMMENTING HE'LL IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THEIR LINE
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR.
LINE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM I A LINE
YOU ARE WELCOME. OKAY HI I'M
SORRY I'M OUT WORK AND I WASN'T
ABLE TO JUMP ON EARLIER FOR- THE
PROCEEDINGS- I AM ACTUALLY- I
NEED YOUR DATE. OF BIRTH OF THE
IF YOU ARE ALREADY I DON'T KNOW
IT'S OKAY IT'S OKAY GIVE ME YOUR
NAME AND IF YOU REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION AND THEN YOUR
TESTIMONY GO AHEAD AND WELCOME
OKAY THE TRUTH I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE- A TRICIA. LEN N. AS E.
L. L. I. O. T. T. I AM NOT WITH
AN ORGANIZATION. OKAY GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR TEST MAY- YES I AM NOT
A VICTIM I- ATTENDED A HEARING
OVER A YEAR AGO AND I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE A LITTLE FEEDBACK
ON- HOW THE VICTIME ORCHESTRA
WILL BECOME- I WAS UNFORTUNATELY
ONE OF THE FIRST ONE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY THE FIRST DAY WHERE THE
DA FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO. REPRESENT ON THE
HEARING AND. I HAD- LET THEM
TWELVE TO PREPARE TO BE IN THE
WITHOUT AT THE START ATTORNEY.
SO IT WAS A VERY TRAUMATIC-
HEARING FOR ME- BASICALLY
SEEING- THE FED MAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THIRTY YEARS HE
WAS A LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE- THE
REASON OF MY CALL TODAY IS
MICHELLE MINOR WITH ONE OF THE
COMMISSIONERS AM. IN GENERAL I
WAS THEM I THINK BUT HEARING
WENT WELL- AS FAR AS WE'RE- AND
PROFESSIONALISM WHAT I WAS.
SAYING WAS. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
NOT HAVE IN FEAR THERE IT WOULD
BEEN NICE TO HAVE A LITTLE.
PRESS QUESTIONS OF THE INMATE
AND MAYBE A LITTLE DEEPER DIVE
INTO. SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
ESPECIALLY THOSE PSYCHOLOGISTS
FOR- AND THEN- I THINK I MEAN
THAT'S BASICALLY ABOUT IT- THERE
WASN'T REALLY ANY WAY THAT-
MYSELF OR ANY OF MY
REPRESENTATIVE COULD YOU CAN
MAKE A CASE FOR THINGS THAT WE
NOW. STILL WERE NOT- I GUESS
OKAY AS FAR AS THE AND MADE-
JUST THE WAY THAT THE HEARING
WENT- I THINK THEY DID THE BEST
THEY CAN AND MAYBE THERE'S MORE
FIX SOME- RIGHT SINCE THAT WAS
THE DAY BUT THAT'S BASICALLY ALL
I WANTED TO SAY MISS. MORE
QUESTION OKAY LET ME ASK A
QUESTION MISSALE- QUICKLY I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR IN FOR YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS OF AT LEAST YOU'RE
COMING- AFFECTED ONE THAT I IT
ASK ABOUT PARTICIPATION OF A
VICTIM'S AND DA'S EXCEPT FOR BUT
ARE YOU CALLING IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION ARE YOU JUST WANT TO
BRING THIS. TO OUR ATTENTION IF
YOU COULD JUST. WHERE ARE. BRING
YOUR ATTENTION I DON'T THERE
WERE SOME OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE
I WILL THAT WAY POLICY- AND MAKE
THE TURN WITH RELATED AND HE
TRIED TO CUT OFF MY-
REPRESENTATIVES A COUPLE TIMES
AND- MISS MINER WAS QUICK TO
REMIND HIM THAT MARSY'S LAW
WITHIN THE FACT THAT. I HAD A
RIGHT IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND IT
IS HOTTER RIGHT TO SPEAK AND
THAT HE COULD NOT INTERRUPT SO
WE DID REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLY- I WOULD SAY JUST MORE
TO BRING SOME AWARENESS OKAY. I
APPRECIATE VRY MUCH THE
COMMITTEE PREACHED APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE WILL DIRECT THAT TO THE BOARD
AND THE COMMISSIONERS OR HEARING
HAVE PERJURED TESTIMONY. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
IN. OKAY THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MADAM MY- ANY FURTHER- WITNESSES
. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU IN A MOMENT- WE WILL
NOW GO TO PEOPLE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION I STILL SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE-
PREPARED TO SPEAK. FROM THE
PUBLIC SO MADAM MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU TO TEE UP
THE CALLS FOR- OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
MADAME MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE IT ALWAYS- SOMEONE TO
COME BACK TO MY- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO JUST TO MAKE IT EASY FOR-
MY SECRETARY AND FOR THE COURT
REPORTER IS I'M GOING TO DO
WITHOUT EACH ONE SEPARATELY- SO.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR WE WILL TAKE ITEM ONE
A. AND THAT IS COMMISSIONER
DIANE DOGS IF I COULD HAVE A
MOTION. THE MOVE THANK YOU
SENATOR KAMLAGER MADE THE MOTION
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH I WROTE I
KAMLAGER HI MARGARET I LAYERED
ALL THERE I BATES ATKINS. HI I
CAN SIDE FORTY ZERO FORTY ZERO
YOU ARE- BUT THE CONFIRMATION
WILL MOVE ONTO THE SENATE FLOOR
CONGRADULATIONS- ITEM ONE B.
COMMISSIONER DAVID LONG A MOTION
. I WOULD MOVE HEAVEN SENATOR
LAYERED HAS MADE THE MOTION
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH NOT VOTING ROVE NOT
VOTING KAMLAGER ALL RIGHT I'M
LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ATKINS HI CONSIDE THROUGH
TO ZERO THAT IS- THREE ZERO AND
- CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSIONER
YOUR APPOINTMENT WILL MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE- FOR FULL
CONFIRMATION. ITEM ONE SEE A
COMMISSIONER MICHELE MINOR- A
MOTION SOME OF SENATOR CALM
WATERS MADE A MOTION- AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WROTE I GREW UP I KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ATKINS HI I CAN SIDE.
ORDERS ZERO ORDER ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSIONER
MINOR IS THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONFIRMATION ITEM ONE D. A
COMMISSIONER EXCEL SURE REEF I
WOULD MOVE COMMISSIONER SHARIA.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GROWTH I GREW UP I KAMLAGER I
LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ATKINS I CAN FIVE FORTY
ZERO BORDER ZERO CAN-
COMMISSIONER SURE REEF- YOUR
APPOINTMENT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONFIRMATION.
ITEM ONE P. COMMISSIONER TROY.
TYRA A MOTION. HELLO SENATE
KAMLAGER THANK YOU OF MATTER SIR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH NO
GROWTH NO. KAMLAGER HI I'M
LONGER ARE LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ATKINS HI ATKINS THREE TWO
ONE THREE TO ONE- COMMISSIONER
ODD TIRING YOUR CUT YOUR
APPOINTMENT MOVE ON THE SENATE
FOR. AS WELL SO LET ME- THANK
EACH OF YOU OBVIOUSLY FOR YOUR
SERVICE- I READ ALL THE
MATERIALS THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF
THE APPOINTMENTS I FEEL YOU DO
NOT GET PAID ENOUGH FOR THE JOB
THAT YOU DO- HOPEFULLY SOMEONE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS
LISTENING AS WE SAY THAT- BUT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND THE
THOUGHTFUL ANSWERS YOU PROVIDED
FOR US TODAY SO CONGRATULATIONS
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO ALL OF YOUR
APPOINTMENTS APPEARING ON THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONFIRMATION.
OKAY WE HAVE TO. CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM I'D TO- F. R. THROUGH K.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR MADAM
SECRETARY AND WATER I KAMLAGER
II FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
AND THEN ON ITEM THREE REFERENCE
OF BILLS TO COMMITTEES. CALL THE
ROLL KAMLAGER THANK KAMLAGER I
BORDER ZERO OR ZERO THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW GO INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION. R. WHICH WILL TAKE A
MINUTE AND THEN WE SHOULD BE
QUICKLY ABLE TO WRAP UP I HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS RIGHT I HAVE TO
MAKE THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
SHE WAS JUST GETTING READY. TO
TELL ME THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S
PUBLIC PORTION OF TE AGENDA. I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY- BUT
YOU WOULD STILL LIKE TO PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS. AGAIN
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN OUR
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. WITH
THAT THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE COOPERATION ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES ONE NOW MOVES
TO EXACT.